wendy's behavior is alarming it's very
sad
you know as i've been watching the shows
recently i'm just saddened by it and i
hope that she goes
and gets some help i guess every day is
not perfect
but i'm not a perfectionist i'm not
perfect
wendy addressed fans today after
struggling through friday's show
to me he's got a lot of mansions
wendy giggled paused awkwardly
and lost focus listen to me you fans
uh-huh hold out oh excuse me
adele after that the 56 year old's
former dj raised more concern on
instagram writing this is going to play
out bad
you're a tough crowd wendy didn't
explain exactly what was going on
but we've seen her struggle before
in 2017 she collapsed on live tv due to
dehydration it was scare weed
back in may wendy took a hiatus from her
show because producers said her graves
disease was causing fatigue
slowly big
wendy's shown symptoms of her immune
system disorder on her show
including anxiety and bulging eyes
she's also been open about her battle
with addiction
i have been living in a sober house
i lost um over a decade of my life
being hooked on cocaine but wendy was
her happy feisty self when i
spoke to her in quarantine in april will
you take care of yourself
excuse me don't talk to me like i'm sick
you take care of yourself
the talk show host was working from home
and anxious to get back to her studio
you're not in love with this why not i
give so much
during my show of myself that the one
place that i've always been able to
count on
to be my own secret little place is home
you